foreign
[Music]
you know I promised your mom that you
would only use this stuff when one of us
was around it's really dangerous Tech I
know it's dangerous what if the cops
took it from you what if you lost it I
didn't lose the suit you have a suit
wait you have a suit I know how to take
care of myself okay trust me I'm pretty
good at it by now
ouch
look I didn't mean it like that I'm
sorry that's okay it's all right I get
it
I just think you should get to have a
normal life
dad a guy dressed like a bee tried to
kill me in my room when I was six
I've never had a normal
how about some music
and in that moment all I could think was
how did the Hulk turn me into a baby
will I be a baby forever am I the hoax
baby dad are you listening to your own
book but I was ready for it no that's uh
Steve this is the radios over there it's
so weird something's wrong with this
switch it won't turn off I said turn it
off
turn it up all right a little after that
I don't think he knew my name
I was just happy to meet a raccoon who
could talk so you've been studying the
quantum Realm
[Music]
why didn't you ask me about it I tried
Mom
a lot you never wanted to talk about it
Cassie's just been curious and we gave
her some pointers this isn't exactly ant
science is it Henry
you know how dangerous the quantum realm
is we all do Mom nobody's going to the
quantum realm that's why we made this
like a satellite for deep space or the
ocean
iguana
we just need a map
and then we can study and explore the
entire Quantum Realm
never even have to go
your daughter built a subatomic Hubble
telescope in a basement
[Music]
this when you were gone and
do I miss the action
sometimes
will I be there when the Avengers need
me absolutely I'd never turn my back on
them
but right now the only job I want is
being a dad
I love you Cassie
thanks for being my hero
and I'm sorry I missed some birthdays
and for the rest of you kids out there
word of advice
look out for the little guy
[Music]
you're an interesting man
Scotland
um I don't know who you are but
you've made a big mistake
okay
I'm an Avenger
I've called the other Avengers you're an
Avenger
have I killed you before
what
they all blow together after a while
you're not the one with the hammer it's
Thor
we get confused a lot similar body types
who are you
just a man
who's lost a lot of time
like you
well we can help each other with that
foreign
like that looks like broccoli
stay here okay
Cassie
oh no
[Music]
okay I have a suit yeah I noticed
you okay yes
look momentum right jump tap right one
move jump tap I know how to do it dad oh
do you yes really because it didn't look
like it from my end I messed up on the
timing jump
like that you see what I did you see
what I did no you're like this small I
jumped into half
you're an interesting man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
we could help each other with that
who are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
give us a second chance
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life will end
up
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
thank you
you thought you could win
I don't have to win
we put yourself to lose
[Music]
I'm sorry Cassie
you come from above
like him
he will burn the world to find you
oh
the Conqueror
Kang the Conqueror is the new iconic
villain in the MCU
we knew we wanted to go to places that
we'd never been
pinning Ant-Man against a major villain
felt perfect
audiences have seen a version of this
character in the series Loki
this is wild
in our film he's very different hang is
an infinite number of different personas
and you need an actor to be able to pull
that off and that is Jonathan majors
I can rewrite existence and shatter
timelines in this film this is really a
side of him we haven't seen this is his
baddest self I will take my revenge on
those who banished me and I will burn
them out of time
I think the film is ultimately about how
time plays within our relationship
love friendship Legacy Ant-Man versus
tank this is it people gonna lose their
mind
yeah if you leave at man
[Music]
I just think you should get to have a
normal life dad a guy dressed like a bee
tried to kill me in my room when I was
six daddy is that you hey peanut
Cassie Lang wants to change the world
I have a suit yeah I noticed she likes
the chaos she wants to be fighting and
she wants to be in the middle of it
she's being influenced by these
superheroes around her
if I had something like this when you
were gone
I could have found you
[Music]
sorry
it was fun watching Catherine take on
Cassie she shows up and she's just got
it
the boy at energy of her character was
so great she just wants to be a
superhero like her dad she wants to
impress him momentum right jump attack I
know how to do it dad oh do you
oh
foreign
[Music]